então o que faz de um seriado o seriado
as férias bebê crescido cada vez mais e
mais ela está muito presente na nossa
vida hoje em dia a mais correcta e às
vezes uma série que a gente visse a
gente gosta tanto
e porque às vezes a gente vê uma série
que no começo a gente acha demais mas
daqui a pouco nem vale mais a pena ver a
gente pode dividir se em dois gêneros
principais a comédia e drama mas por
agora vai ser mais importante drama
então a gente fica nele
uma das grandes diferenças entre a
comédia eo drama é que na série de drama
a gente tem de parar de ver no meio mais
que na de comédia ou a gente vê tudo e
sabe que no começo era bem melhor que o
primeiro problema o motivo que faz o que
fazer e para a dever ser ii em relação a
um bom exemplo de onde quer chegar é o
primeiro liars e que ele te dá o qual é
o mistério inicial
no primeiro episódio mas ele rola muito
até te dizer qualquer
eu conheço muita gente que não viu ele
até o final porque ele não levava nada
outro caso parecido é diferente é o
lanche que ele também estava o mistério
inicial mas em vez de solucionar ele ele
estava mais mistérios em cima e
problemas que às vezes nem eram
solucionados enquanto ele criava
expectativa para o final que muita gente
não gostou
ai tem um event que é sobre uma mulher
emily que nela está procurando as
pessoas que fizeram mau pai dela e se
vingando se aqui no meio à cnn que pede
foco e não é a mesma coisa em roma
demais e não fica bom
o segundo problema acontece quando uma
série sai da sua premissa original ou
seja do foco que ela tinha quando ele
começou então ela vira uma coisa
diferente e as pessoas não ficam tão
interessadas no glee a série
indiscutivelmente a baixa qualidade na
quarta temporada quando usou vários
atores principais personagens eles
inevitavelmente se formam no colégio que
é onde toda a série se passa e agora
eles têm que dividir o foco entre os
alunos que estão no colégio e os alunos
que já saíram então a série muda muito
no piso um break também acontece uma
coisa inevitável
como o próprio nome diz é sobre a fuga
de uma prisão mas que acontece quando
eles escapam não vai ser mais aquela
coisa que tinha aprendido na primeira
temporada o san antonio árias que tem
maior a qualificação geral são a
primeira e terceira que pequeno spoiler
se passa em prisões no nosso planetário
acontece uma coisa parecida que as
temporadas que as pessoas mais gostam
sendo a primeira à terceira e na
primeira desculpa ea segunda ea quinta
que se passam todas no lugar onde tudo
começou
que é a cidade onde eles moram
o terceiro problema repetição e o caso
do sul tiveram os modelos são muito
complicados porque são duas séries muito
boas mas que ainda tem bastante gente
que não assiste tudo isso por causa da
repetição nas duas séries os personagens
passam pelos mesmos problemas várias
vezes ea história por ser directamente
então as ruas para um desvio no meio
mesmo que em alguns casos ele fique boa
de novo depois o quarto problema não vou
poder falar muito porque mesmo que tenha
falado de alguns jogos e sei que vai ser
muito spoiler am
mas quando você chega no final é muito
difícil acabar ela porque né e aí o
final fica ruim na visão de muita gente
então a gente essas problemas em relação
à saída da primeira final
a repetição de um filme ruim a gente tem
uma série direta com a mesma província
sempre com novidades e com um futebol e
mesmo que a primeira isso não pareça
muito difícil é muito difícil dizer
primeiramente a gente tem que ter a
mesma de sempre com novidades
ou seja a mesma coisa só que diferente e
tem a campanha da melissa que de 1997 a
melissa marca de sapatinho mesmo que
dizia sempre igual sempre diferente e é
assim que tem que ser uma série ela tem
que ser igual a efectivo e assim a coisa
natural
ele é uma série médica com três
temporadas que ainda não acabou e que
ele mantém o foco desde sempre que a
vida dentro do hospital ele não enrola e
ele não se repete tanto que as
temporadas que isso
tendem a gostar mais sua nona ea décima
que são bem gente ao contrário do
campeonato e tem muitas séries que as
pessoas preferem no começo que tudo
inédito de surpreende não enjoa depois e
então a gente fala de outras séries que
nenhum grande anatomy que ainda não
acabaram e conseguem não ter esses
problemas o cuba que não é mais fácil
porque o episódio não tem uma ligação
obrigatória entre eles e tudo isso é uma
crítica à sociedade moderna e a conversa
dela com a tecnologia mas o caso do tal
cerro é muito inteligente
eles têm a mesma premissa desde 1963
só que de tempos em tempos ultimamente
de duas em duas temporadas
o ator principal ou no caso do doutor
ele muda e junto com ele muda a
personalidade geral do personagem e
ajudante dele fazendo a série ficar cada
vez fez cá e nós já o caso de chi de
fins é mais resistente e ainda deu tempo
dele fica ruim amas
eu acho que vale a pena falar dele
porque hoje ele como foi feito é genial
ele tem elementos secundários e modernos
que faziam serviço é muito boa de
assistir ele a partir do chamado
algoritmo do netflix
ele é feito para o bingbot a ação de
assistir vários episódios seguidas ele
tem crianças o que chama a atenção entre
tem muita gente
ele dá um certo medinho assim ele tem
uma baita nostalgia dos anos oitenta e
dois atores famosos da época que fazer
era ficar muito muito viciante e todo
mundo fica ansioso para a próxima
temporada
e aí o que mostrou uns que é uma série
com muitos personagens uma história
muito complexa mas quem desce mais
assistida por aí ela não se enrola ela
tem os mesmos jogos do começo e ela não
se repete três vezes eu até surpreende
demais e aí mas essa série é excepcional
e não é por nada o criador do escritor
dos livros o jorge a martin já sabe como
ele vai acabar e
ele não dirigiu isso enquanto escrevia
tipo o quarto livro ele sabia como ia
acabar a série antes comecei a escrever
o primeiro livro e no final esse é o
grande segredo o que me leva a um grande
exemplo dessa teoria que é o corte médio
o criador do black bear do vince
gilligan ele sabia desde o começo como é
que ele ia acabar a série
mesmo que ele tenha feito algumas
pequenas mudanças
quando ofereci quando ele acabou a série
ofereceram um milhão de dólares por
episódio que ele fizesse depois do
finale
mas ele não aceitou porque era daquele
jeito que ele tinha que acabar e é um
baita final o que nos leva a última
solução do nosso problema
o fim bom mas depois de analisar tudo
isso qual é o seriado ideal e o que eu
faço e quero fazer uma série de sucesso
essas perguntas não tem uma resposta
absoluta porque mesmo que tenha que ser
direto que têm a mesma premissa sempre
que seja com novidades e com um filhote
mua item 1 milhão e uma outras coisas
que podem dar errado e ninguém repete em
bola de propósito também não é tão
simples fazer uma série precisa de um
roteiro uma produção um elenco e muitas
coisas podem se qualificar a série mesmo
tendo todos esses pontos
então o único jeito de saber se gosta ou
não de uma série é assistindo então
quando chegar em casa hoje
sentei no sofá relaxa e assistir um dois
ou três episódios aquela série que está
todo mundo dizendo pra ver obrigada